REPLACE THE QUEEN AS HEAD OF
STATE.
WE GET MORE ON WHY THIS HAPPENED
FROM CNN'S MAX FOSTER.
>> Reporter: I DO SWEAR THAT I
WILL WELL AND TRULY SERVE
BARBADOS.
55 YEARS AFTER GAINING
INDEPENDENCE FROM THE UK,
BARBADOS CUTS ITS LAST FORMAL
TIE.
THE ROYAL STANDARD FLAG LOWERED
AND REPLACED BY THE PRESIDENTIAL
STANDARD, MARKING THE END OF THE
QUEEN'S REIGN ON THIS ISLAND.
AND A NEW FUTURE UNDER A
BARBADOS HEAD OF STATE APPOINTED
BY THE PARLIAMENT.
>> OUR COUNTRY AND OUR PEOPLE
MUST DREAM BIG DREAMS AND FIGHT
IT REALIZE THEM.
PRINCE CHARLES INVITED AS A
GUEST OF HONOR AMONG THE LIKES
OF POP STAR RIHANNA.
HE USED THE MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE BRITAIN'S ROLE IN
THE SLAVE TRADE.
>> FROM THE DARKEST DAYS OF OUR
PAST, AND THE APPALLING ATROCITY
OF SLAVERY, WHICH FOREVER STAINS
OUR HISTORY, THE PEOPLE OF THIS
ISLAND FORGED THEIR PATH WITH
EXTRAORDINARY FORTITUDE.
>> Reporter: IT WAS UNUSUALLY
STARK LANGUAGE FROM THE UK, BUT
DISAPPOINTED THOSE HOLDING OUT
FOR A FORMAL APOLOGY.
>> IT IS PART OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY.
THE ROYAL FAMILY CONTRIBUTED TO
SLAVERY.
THE ROYAL FAMILY BENEFITED FROM
SLAVERY FINANCIALLY.
AND MANY OF OUR AFRICAN BROTHERS
AND SISTERS DIED IN BATTLE,
OKAY, FOR CHANGE.
>> Reporter: IT WAS IN THE 1620s
THAT BRITISH SETTLERS ARRIVED IN
THIS PARADISE AND THEY WENT ON
TO BUILD VAST FORTUNES FROM THE
SUGAR AND THE SLAVE TRADES.
CALLS FOR COMPENSATION OF THAT
DARK PERIOD IF BRITISH HISTORY
GREW LOUDER DURING THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER PROTESTS AS DID THE
PUSH TO A REPUBLIC.
>> CLEARLY PEOPLE IN AFRICA, IN
THIS REGION, IN ALL PARTS OF THE
WORLD STILL FEEL THAT PROFOUND
SENSE OF INJUSTICE AND IT IS
QUITE RIGHT WE RECOGNIZE THAT,
WE ARE DETERMINED THAT SUCH A
THING COULD NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> Reporter: THE QUEEN IS STILL
HEAD OF STATE IN 15 COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD AND REPUBLICAN
MOVEMENTS IN THOSE NATIONS WILL
BE LOOKING FOR WHAT HAS HAPPENED
HERE IN BARBADOS AND HOPING THAT
THIS WILL ADD MOMENTUM TO THEIR
OWN CAMPAIGN.
>> MAX FOSTER JOINING US LIVE
FROM BARBADOS.
WEATHER LOOKS GOOD.
WHAT DOES A COUNTRY GET OUT OF
BEING PART OF THE CROWN.
AND WAS THIS DECISION TO LEAVE
CONTROVERSIAL, MAX?
>> Reporter: IT WAS
CONTROVERSIAL, I THINK IT WAS
SEEN AS INEVITABLE THAT IT
HAPPENED AT SOME POINT.
SOME CONTROVERSY AROUND THE
TIMING OF IT, PERHAPS THE
GOVERNMENT RUSHED THIS THROUGH
SOONER THAN IT NEEDED TO HAPPEN.
THE PRESIDENT WAS APPOINTED BY
PARLIAMENT, VOTED FOR BY
PARLIAMENT BUT THE PUBLIC WASN'T
GIVEN A SAY ON WHO THAT
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE AND SOME
CAMPAIGNERS SAID TO ME IT IS A
REAL SHAME THAT THE PUBLIC
DIDN'T HAVE THEIR CHANCE TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS MOMENT OF
HISTORY.
BUT BROADLY THE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
THERE IS SOME CONCERN THAT
LOOKING FORWARD, APART FROM THE
EXCITEMENT OF THE INDEPENDENCE,
ABOUT THE TRADE TIES THAT THE
ISLAND HAS WITH THE UK, SOME
CONCERN THAT THEY'RE BECOMING
TOO RELIANT ON CHINESE
INVESTMENT.
SPEAK TO A LOT OF YOUNGER PEOPLE
AND THEY DO TALK ABOUT THIS
CONCERN ABOUT CHINESE INVESTMENT
ON THE ISLAND, PERHAPS THEY
SHOULD BE STICKING WITH THE UK,
BUT THE SAME TIME THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE HAVING THE QUEEN AS
HEAD OF STATE.
IT IS A COMPLICATED LAYERED
CULTURAL DEBATE HERE.
BROADLY PEOPLE ARE HAPPY IT IS
NOW A REPUBLIC, NOT NECESSARILY
HAPPY WITH THE TIMING OF IT.
>> SOME CELEBS IN ATTENDANCE,
INCLUDING RIHANNA.
EXPLAIN.
>> Reporter: WELL, RIHANNA, YOU
KNOW, YOU DRIVE AROUND BARBADOS
AND HER PICTURE IS EVERYWHERE,
SHE'S IN THE GRAFFITI, IN
POSTERS, SHE IS THE NATION'S
SWEETHEART, SHE IS A HUGE
MEGASTAR HERE.
SHE IS BARBADIAN, OF COURSE.
BUT I THINK WHAT IS VERY
INTERESTING LAST NIGHT IS THAT
THE PRESIDENT'S FIRST HONOR THAT
SHE CONFERRED WAS TO PRINCE
CHARLES, GAVE HIM A FREEDOM
AWARD, SOME FOUND CONTROVERSIAL,
BUT THE SECOND ONE SHE GAVE OUT
WAS TO RIHANNA, CALLING HER A
HERO OF THE NATION.
AND SHE IS NOW UP THERE FOR THE
BIG NATIONAL EVENTS, SITTING
THERE ALONGSIDE THE LIKES OF
PRINCE CHARLES.
THE MESSAGING THERE WAS REALLY
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN
HUGELY SUCCESSFUL AND SHE IS
YOUNG AND SHE'S DYNAMIC AND SHE
REALLY POINTS TO THE FUTURE.
SO